oh what an empty world it would be
without music alright I'm gonna do
something that I've been pondering doing
for a very long time and I kind of allow
myself to get a little bit more
self-indulgent more than I already do at
the sort of the tail end of the year so
I'm gonna throw this here this is my top
10 best movie soundtracks a couple rules
for how I laid this out and obviously
these are my personal choices I haven't
listened every soundtrack ever but let
me lay this out the first is when I say
soundtrack what I actually mean is score
it's film scores that I'm talking about
so these are not collections of songs
this is not like the the Pulp Fiction
soundtrack that's not what I'm talking
about I am talking about the film scores
written by a composer specifically for a
film the other thing is I made a rule
for myself that no composer can be on
this list more than one time because
otherwise this basically would be a list
of only three composers and just a whole
bunch of movies that they worked on so
that did mean I had to make some very
hard decisions with some of these folks
but with those having been established
let's get to it
first I'm actually going to do an
honorable mention for one that I wanted
to include but could not decide how to
credit it and that is the soundtrack to
parts of the Caribbean curse of the
Black Pearl now it's officially credited
to Klaus
bad bad delt Bay delt I'm not sure how
to pronounce his last name the thing is
though is that he is a sort of a pupil
to Hans Zimmer and the more I looked
into it the more it looked like Hans
Zimmer kind of ghost wrote a lot of that
soundtrack and then Hans Zimmer took
over for the for the sequels and since
I've got Hans Zimmer on this list for
something else but it also didn't write
to credit did it to him
like that I kind of had to disqualify
this one but I love this soundtrack I
don't want to mention it anyway so
secret number 11 I guess okay list
proper number 10 Jerry Goldsmith with
the soundtrack to the original Planet of
the Apes Jerry Goldsmith was a was a
composer I knew was gonna be on here and
he has had an amazing body of work but
the very dissonant and sort of abstract
but highly evocative soundtrack to the
original Planet of the Apes it's a an
amazing piece of work it is intense and
it did you like there'll be little bits
and stings like a couple / like of a
drum like I don't know where and there's
always a tension and a weirdness to it
and yet it at the same time feels
organic to how weird the situation is it
feels like the perfect soundtrack for
this strange situation
it's a strange score but man I love it
so number nine we now do get to my
actual Hans Zimmer
entry The Lion King now this does not
include the songs because that way you
know those were other folks working on
that note this is just the score and I
know a lot of people think about Lion
King music and they think about circle
of life can't wait to be king you know
can you feel the love tonight and all
that but the the music and the scores
and the things linking between the
actual musical numbers you know across
the the pride lands the the there's a
sense of wonder and majesty right
especially towards the end you know in
the in the climax and sort of the
triumph of it with Simba at the end it
really is a really enveloping piece of
music it kinda takes you to that place
so well and like Hans Zimmer has done a
lot of great music and this was one of
those ones that was tough to call but
ultimately when I saw a list of
everything down I'm like I gotta give it
to that one so moving along to number
eight I have to do have somewhere on
here a soundtrack from Miyazaki film so
that does mean I am at Joe Hisaishi
I hope I pronounced that at least
vaguely right and he's done I think
every soundtrack from Miyazaki if not
every soundtrack almost every sound
track for me though the one that I will
always come back to is Princess Mononoke
because it has the the smaller quieter
more whimsical sort of lighter fairy
touch that is present in a lot of his
soundtracks adidas for Miyazaki for
obvious reasons but it also has an app
that extra touch of epic scope that the
grander story of Princess Mononoke
demands and the like the main theme in
that is a wonderful sweeping piece of
music and again
it just makes you feel like you're
standing you know looking out over a
forest it is oh that's beautiful so next
stop another anime soundtrack for number
7 this one from Kenji Kawai and it is
the ghost in the shell' the original
anime film soundtrack and ghost of most
ghosts in the show products at least
that I have seen cuz then see the
live-action remake by choice I have had
a really good music and you know stand
alone complex has had great music but
the that score for the original ghost in
the shell' like and the haunting nosov
it like especially during the opening
credits the the making of a cyborg
soundtrack and yeah it has
the sense of ominous Ness and yet also a
weird kind of sense of hope it's like
it's like celebrating and mourning all
at once
and it has one of my favorite single
tracks of movie music ever which is the
floating Museum which is you used during
the climax with with the major and that
tank I got I love that piece and it's a
great soundtrack besides so from here
we're gonna go up one number six Daft
Punk Tron Legacy there have been a
couple of like only a couple of movies
in my life that one of my first thoughts
when the movie was over was I need that
music I need it now and this was
absolutely one of them the film itself
is okay it's visually pretty cool the
story has neat ideas that it doesn't go
deep enough on and it you know it's it's
fine but the way that I enjoy this movie
is basically by treating it as a
two-hour Daft Punk music video cuz the
music is great like I I have a really
weird sort of relationship with techno
and electronic music which is that I am
capable of liking it even loving it but
I don't like sort of the standard
generic electronic techno kind of music
like if you were to find what Mosley
would be you would consider to be
standard techno mic I'm gonna get bored
with this really quick but there is such
there is that feeling of an orchestral
build even as there's all this
electronic music but it has you know the
heavy horns but it always has that
thumping electronic beat like oh man and
it gives you again that that sense of
another world and it it's so good
I wish the movie was as good as this
soundtrack that would have been amazing
number five time for me to talk about
Danny Elfman and Danny Elfman
soundtracks haven't grabbed me in a long
time
but I will never ever tire and never
stop going back to the soundtrack to
Batman from 1989 that to me is that is
Batman music I think Batman that is the
music that place in my head and I loved
Hans Zimmer's work on Nolan's film
especially in the Dark Knight but it's
still this the the sense of darkness of
foreboding this but also like this sort
of undercurrent of heroism it doesn't
feel like oppressive darkness it does
feel like there's a light in this dark
and it's just it's so perfect it's
perfect not only for Tim Burton's
version of Batman is perfect for Batman
and it got solidified with how that
field got adapted for the Batman
animated series different composer for
that but it was obviously very much
taken in that vein and in that style and
that to me just is Batman music and it's
haunting and it's beautiful and it's
intense at the right moments and it's
silly at times with the Joker tracks oh
why are these all so good number four
another more recent film and one whose
soundtrack I have talked about in other
videos before John Powell with How to
Train Your Dragon he also did How to
Train Your Dragon 2 which is very good
but there's something about the first
time with this and there are a few
soundtracks that I can think that I
would describe as soaring this
soundtrack source and it is one of the
most gloriously triumphant pieces of
music I mean it's a wonderfully
triumphant movie series even it's one of
the things I love about it and to have
that so perfectly encapsulated in the
music especially in the track is that
these come back around again or Joe
maybes just come back around which is is
used for the very end of the film just
the way it sort of it builds and then it
lulls and it's it's sort of a
it feels like flight it's sort of Lauzon
that's gliding and then it's soars it
takes off and I I get choked up just
hearing it like it gives me that much of
an emotional rush and not because I it
makes me think of like a sad part of a
movie because it makes me think of the
awesomeness and the glorious victory and
triumph of something and I think person
because it's not a necessarily a sense
of triumph over somebody else it's a
sense of triumph in just dealing with
life and obstacles and differences and
yes there are there's still like a
villain in this film but it's not the
movies not about triumphing over the
villain and so the music doesn't feel
like we're trying to wait we're having a
sense of triumph because we beat
somebody like no we're having a sense of
triumph because we overcame oh oh that's
a great soundtrack number three we get a
pretty unique one here which is why it's
on here not only that it's on here but
it's as high as it is
Vangelis Blade Runner nothing before
Blade Runner sounded like Blade Runner
there have been a handful of things
after Blade Runner that sounded like
Blade Runner but it's because they're
trying to sound like Blade Runner the
Blade Runner soundtrack is this mix of
electronic ambience with jazz with blues
with the sense of longing this very new
are feeling vibe of we're just trying to
get by in this world and it's a feel I
love from the film and the soundtrack is
a big part of the reason why that
feeling is there and it can have darker
moments but for me it's ultimately
things like Rachel's song and
the Bladerunner or love theme that
really just hammer home how well this
film connects with me and it nails the
loneliness and the melancholy of these
characters it embodies it in the music
itself and like I said it just doesn't
sound like anything else oh boy it's
really good only a couple left now now
next we get to the one that is the the
composer everybody knew who was gonna be
on here the soundtrack I picked probably
not the one most would have put on here
for him though but we'll see
so John Williams you know had to knew
there was gonna be John Williams on here
because I mean how could you not but
like what John Williams I mean the the
guy practically wrote the soundtrack to
my geekdom you know he he did jaws and
Star Wars and and like every not just
like the original like all the Star Wars
movies and most of Spielberg movies he
did et he did Superman like oh my god
how do I pick one well ultimately the
one that I landed on as being what I
think is the best exemplar of what he
does and just how good he is
it's the soundtrack to Raiders of the
Lost Ark so why this one and that's kind
of the thing like I wouldn't have to
justify putting John Williams on here I
do kind of have to explain why I went
with this one and I think there's a
couple of reasons first of all it's got
a great overture and a great theme which
is the man's specialty but it's also got
I think the best non highlighted tracks
as well because oftentimes I'll find
myself with the Williams score
keeping to the big numbers and sometimes
skipping over you know the smaller
moments because the the music doesn't
draw me in as much I don't do that with
this one I listen to the whole thing
start to finish
I never skip a track and the sense of
awe and mystery or with the with the
music that is used you know to build up
the the sense of just the unknown around
the arc itself is great in Dee's music
is obviously astounding but there's
actually the track that solidified this
for me and why I had to pick this one
it's an odd one the track is called the
desert chase and it's a specific moment
so the desert chase is it's the whole
scene where Indy goes after the truck he
starts out on a horse he's got a so he
climbs along the truck throws out the
driver the whole bunch of Nazis in the
back they're coming out they're crawling
around he's got to shake them off you
like run up against trees and and bump
into other cars and all this other stuff
so that's the that's the track that's
going on the moment that made me go oh
this is why it's got to be number one
there's a point at which there's only
one Nazi left in the back of the truck
that India's driving and this is a
character we've never seen before got no
history on no clue who this dude is he's
just another Nazi and instead of
climbing along his side he climbs up
over the top to get to the cab to get to
Indy and the music that plays while he's
crawling across does all of the work to
make you afraid for Indy because at this
point he's been shaken off Nazis left
and right like we shouldn't be afraid of
one more Nazi like okay maybe we know
Indies a little tired but like he's
taking all these other ones out but the
music builds the tension the music tells
you this dude right now is a big problem
and I honestly I put that all down to
the music in that moment like it just it
sells what otherwise doesn't quite play
and that is the magic of what John
Williams can do at his best and I do
think Raiders of the Lost Ark is him at
his best but I did not take my
number-one spot now what is at number
one is a composer who I actually think
in the breadth and scope of his career
is an inferior composer to most of the
other composers on this list but this
one soundtrack is my all-time favorite
movie soundtrack the composer is James
Horner the soundtrack is Braveheart
James Horner is a composer that I can
get very frustrated with he he could do
good work but he also self plagiarized a
lot he would reuse the same like three
or four no brass sting ominous little
didn't any brass sting in more movies
than I can count off the top of my head
I first noticed it in Willow and since
then I've noticed it in Star Trek the
Wrath of Khan the perfect storm
the the mask of Zoro avatar like it it
keeps turning up and and if you know
enough of his work you can pick out more
things that he just keeps reusing again
and again again none of which are
evident in Braveheart and the blending
of the bagpipes with a more traditional
Kestrel score creates something unique
something really beautiful something
that to this day I I just can't get
enough of and I think in much the same
way that you know Daft Punk took a type
of music that I like I can be iffy on
and but managed to use that and convey
it in a way that really connects with me
is the same thing here with the bagpipes
because I don't have an inherent love of
bagpipes I mean they're fine
I don't find them unattractive as
instruments but like I'm not like yeah
bagpipes but their use here and the
mournfulness of them here but also at
times the sort of the the unifying
themes used through them or the or the
Irish whistles for the princesses theme
its I am I will always be bowled over by
this soundtrack and I will never get
tired of listening to it and if I'm ever
down if I'm having a lousy day this is
one of those things that I can put on
and it may not automatically make my day
better but it will soothe my soul and
that's why for me it's my favorite
soundtrack of any film so that is my
list I have to imagine that other
people's lists wildly different so
favorite movie soundtrack or film score
or however you want to classify it what
is it for you whatever it is drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it what what just up you can
do because there's buttons and links
including one to my patron if you feel
like supporting me that way if you don't
don't worry other links you can check
out don't want to click on them that's
fine too because at the end of the day
folks you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]